At a formal level,
there are different ways to define what an elementary operation is, depending upon what
computational model we're using.
For example, an elementary operation could be one step of a Turing machine if we were using that model.
For the purposes of this lesson, we're gonna be focusing on circuit models, as I've already stated, and specifically quantum
and Boolean circuits.
When we're working with circuits, it's typical that we think about each gate as representing an elementary operation.
We've seen several different quantum gates thus far in the series,
including X, Y and Z gates, Hadamard gates, S and T gates,
controlled NOT gates, swap gates, Toffoli gates, and Fredkin gates.
We also talked about query gates in the context of the query model, but we're not going to be working within the query model in this lesson, so we won't worry about
query gates for now.
We also saw that any unitary operation on any number of qubits
can be viewed as a gate if we want to do that.
For the purposes of measuring cost though, that's not going to be very helpful, so what we're going to do is we're simply going
to pick a set of gates
and we'll view that set as being our set of elementary operations.
First, we'll include the
single qubit unitary gates that you see here,
namely X, Y and Z gates,
Hadamard gates and S and T gates, as well as their inverses
or conjugate transposes.
We don't actually need all of these gates. As soon as we have Hadamard and T gates, we can implement the rest of them,
but just for the sake of convenience, we're gonna include all of them.
We'll also include controlled NOT gates, and these will be the only
multiple qubit gates in our set.
And finally we'll include single-qubit standard basis measurements so that we can actually get some classical information
coming out of our circuits.
If we focus just on the unitary gates and forget about the
measurements for a moment, we obtain what's called
a universal gate set.
What that means is that
any unitary operation on any number of qubits can
either be implemented exactly
or arbitrarily closely
with a quantum circuit built out of just these gates.
In other words, this is a
good enough set of gates that we can build any unitary
operation out of them.
Not necessarily exactly, but we can get as good an
approximation as we want.
That might require a lot of gates, and it's actually not too hard to reason that it must require a
lot of gates sometimes,
but nevertheless, it's always possible.
It's not a simple matter to prove that this is a universal gate set though, and we won't discuss how
that's done in the series,
but it is a pretty well known fact and there are in fact different
ways that it can be proved.
There are also other gate sets that are sometimes used
instead of this one, such as Toffoli gates, Hadamard gates, and S gates in addition to measurements,
but this is a pretty standard choice.
So in summary, these are
the quantum operations that we'll view as being elementary.
For Boolean circuits,
we're going to consider these four gates to be
elementary operations: AND gates, OR gates, NOT gates and FANOUT.
FANOUT, by the way, is not
always counted as being a gate, but it's going to be
important for us to do this as we will see later in the lesson.
Similar to what we had for
our standard quantum gate set, this set is a little bit redundant.
You don't need both AND and OR. You can create either one using the other with three NOT gates,
but it doesn't hurt to include both and it's just convenient.
As you may already know, this is a universal gate set
for deterministic computations, meaning that any function
from bits to bits
can be implemented with a Boolean circuit composed of gates from this collection.
Once again, just like we
had for quantum circuits, this doesn't mean that every function can be implemented efficiently
by a Boolean circuit,
and indeed most functions
can only be implemented with very large circuits
for the simple reason that there are lots and lots of functions
and they can't all have small circuits. There just aren't enough
small circuits to go around.
Universality is easier
to prove in this case than in the quantum case as it turns out.
So if you don't already
know how to prove it, give it some thought and
see if you can figure it out if you're so inclined.
Now that we've decided on the
gates we're going to allow and we're going to consider
to be elementary operations, we can think about how many of them
are required to perform
various computations.
To do that, we'll make
use of this definition for the size of a circuit.
This definition works for both
Boolean and quantum circuits and it's very simple.
The size of a circuit is the
total number of gates it has.
For example, if we return
to the same example we've seen several times, which is our Boolean circuit for computing the exclusive OR of two bits,
we see that it has size seven
because there's seven gates, two FANOUT gates, two NOT gates,
two AND gates and one OR gate. If we decided not to count
FANOUT gates, which is common, it would have size equal to five,
but we are going to count FANOUT gates, so its size is seven.